[Musique]
plus
depuis que nous avons commencé à administrer le
vaccin contre le paludisme en septembre 2019,
nous avons constaté une réduction des cas de
paludisme
et même des enfants qui contractent le paludisme,
ce n'est pas grave
et le nombre de décès dus au paludisme
a également diminué
[Musique]
dale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si vous réduisez ce chiffre de
40,
vous pourrez voir l'impact que cela aura
tout d'abord sur les familles, elles
n'auront pas à dépenser d'argent pour aller dans les
établissements de santé, elles n'en auront pas.  ils n'auront pas à
dépenser d'argent pour acheter des médicaments,
ils n'auront pas à dépenser d'argent pour
assister aux funérailles et aussi sur le
système de santé, le nombre d'
enfants arrivant à l'hôpital est
réduit
[Musique]
vous